every human being models the world to
understand it and that's cognitively how
we're successful so I don't look at a
chair and see a huge number of molecules
or some very complex structure I see a
chair this is something that's very hard
to teach a computer to do to understand
conceptual things forward right and we
conceptualize right away we theorize
right away I have a theory of what that
object is in my theory is that it's a
chair and that's what helps human beings
be so adaptable in the world and so fast
and moving through the world and and
it's precisely this ability to theorize
and model but we also know that by doing
so we are projecting a theory of the
world on the world and we trick
ourselves we deceive ourselves sometimes
the trick is to to use the the power
that's given to us by being able to
conceptualize and and model and have
metaphor but always to remember that
that's what we're doing and to always
when you come to a point there is in
some sense no such thing as knowing
something's true it's true in the
context of the model of the world that
you have and and maybe there's a
different model of the world where that
truth is a little bit different I mean
I'm in no position to talk about
interpersonal relationships but I think
that this is a problem between people
that we have a theory of the world and
things mean certain things in that
context and we forget that somebody else
has a different theory of the world and
the exact same experience means
something very different as a
theoretical physicist I rely very much
on calculating to understand results so
let's say I want to know what happens
when
big black hole swallows a little tiny
black hole my starting point will be to
think what's my first mathematical
sentence that I know if I crack it open
will answer this question
not even that step can be very hard and
then once I do that I'll be moving very
in a very structured way through the
steps to unlock that but it's kind of
sometimes it's like a Rubik's Cube which
I'm actually not good at but you know
some people can just go and solve it and
some people just keep making a bigger
mess right and so as a physicist you
want your skill to improve to the point
where you can just sort of unlock this
thing I find it very interesting when I
work with much younger students I like
to kind of sit back in the room when
we're calculating now and and ask them
to try to find the solution and in the
way that's you know we do know how to go
one step after another but I'll be
trying at the same time to try to find
that cute way of unpacking it that's
highly non-obvious and sometimes I'm
sitting there for two days
well there you know generating 12 pages
are very tough beautifully done
calculations where I'm trying to find a
way to try to do it in a half a page and
sometimes I succeed and sometimes I
don't you know sometimes I can't do that
it's just not possible or I haven't
figured out how to do it and sometimes I
do and when you do it's not just that
it's shorter it's that you're working
with such bigger structures that you can
see so much more at a time I don't know
how else to explain it you know how how
chess players see a lot of the game at
one time in one sort of thought they see
many plays and many and you know it's
also I don't play chess because I see
one play at a time right and I think
that's the difference it's not just that
it's shorter it's that in some sense
you've seen many plays at a time but in
terms of the ambiguity our calculations
have to be exact we can't be like oh I'm
not really sure it's something like this
and there is an art to approximating for
sure especially in astrophysics but the
kinds of calculations I tend to do are
very precise and there are there are no
approximations and there's no skipped
steps but that's not reality so
everything we've ever looked at in the
universe is an approximation we only
know the number pi to some number of
digits we don't know every digit and PI
nor will we ever and so in some sense pi
can't be measured it's it's it's our
it's an abstract thought but it's not
something that can ever exist in reality
when I tell you the mass of the electron
I always have to end at some precision
where I no longer know for sure what the
numbers are that follow and so in some
sense in reality we never have the
precision we have in the mathematics on
the page and that's an interesting
ambiguity to think about I mean do
precise numbers exist in reality is
there anything that whose value is one
you know we there isn't because the best
we can do is say it's close to one at
some precision that we've been able to
observe